and as a more motive when the mother
became so was the first
hotel brand that
had already happened very much on the internet and she focused very much on
the internet and
then it was just obvious that it
was no longer about the stars but it
was really about ratings and that
Back then, nobody really
noticed that the feedback from the guests was
no longer in
long letters or something else, bang,
that comes immediately the next day or
on the same day, that
is actually on the Internet, now
certainly one of the best podcasts,
maybe even of all time  Top ten
podcast of all time at OMR, with
Dieter Müller, who is the founder
of Motel One and who has written a story with it.
These
decades, there is only
very rarely a founder of his own
funds or who
has actually become a billionaire  his idea
and the idea can also be
understood by everyone, namely a hotel chain,
you would think a hotel would have nothing
special, it really isn't,
but the way he changes the entire
industry, the ideas, the
creativity, the disruption that is
infectious behind mother, that's Dieter Müller
and that's why I was
very happy to have the conversation and the conversation
really kept everything
going, hi,
thanks for the invitation, yes, I'm
obviously curious for a variety of reasons, but
maybe I started right at the beginning, so to speak, you
're a hotelier from the very early
hour or  not quite so after
graduating from school I did something else for a very short time
but then went to the
hotelier early on yes
big coincidence because Aqua came to Germany
then I took a look at what
they were doing there and I went to the construction site
and happened to be the
one developing it  should be in
Germany was sitting in the baubote
and then we talked very well
and then he
hired me right away it was
really and well there is a
story you can read that you
really walk past the construction site
or
22 okay and  then I wish you
Bonn Hotel I'm no longer curious take
a look and then they hired you
but you always
did the training you originally did exactly I
still did training at BMW big from the
outside apart so it has nothing
to do with the hotel industry
well  I've always liked the
hotels I just couldn't
afford it okay but then he
immediately resigned from this BMW life
and said okay I'll try it
someone approached me or
signed me up immediately now I'm doing
exactly
one  Made a trip from Berlin to
BMW and then Saarlanders are stuck on the
floe, then I'm back and
jobs have never been
particularly richly blessed Saarland and
then you always looked at what was happening
there and that's how it came about
listed hotel company is
still quite large and that you
then worked as an employee for the first almost ten years,
exactly
13 years was a very small company at the time
and was still called a
hotel,
so to this day one of the brands of
Accord was the nucleus
actually and Saarbrücken was the first
hotel outside of France so
very small companies were still a
bit chaotic as it is always the case
when you are small and when
you grow a lot and that was the
great opportunity to really take part in everything, to
experience everything  how do
I get a piece of land how do
I finance how do I run the business and that
was a great great story how
enormously much I learned back then
or if
two reasons
were called pellison and Brühl who
unfortunately one of the two just died
it started as a
family business, however, because
it grew very quickly, it
was on the capital market very quickly and it was okay
to finance the growth, ne, which
area of ​​the hotel industry is the
most important, so what what do you need to
know best that is the kitchen are the
rooms are they the building plots  what
you do best very well you
first have to build and develop a hotel
so the areas are
forbidden one into the other one does
n't work without the other no and um that starts
of course you have to find land there you
have to find good sheets that
are suitable  it
's actually pre-programmed that you can be successful
[music]
and then of course it works. Financing
is also an important issue because it's a
very capital-intensive
hotel project or a hotel building is
the capital, so you have to
set up good financing,
find investors who will take part and then it's done
the thing didn't
work out so after these 13 years of
employment, so to speak, you
then decided to be king yourself
simply because you saw the opportunity
or because you didn't like it anymore
in the job or no it's
my savings really a chance there
and  it all
started in this hotel here it was
my first,
my first own hotel in the Achental
in Chiemsee and at that time the hotel belonged to the
Bavarian President Willi Otto Hoffmann
and he got into financial
difficulties and Akku had it for
him  run as a management contract
and then the bank said we did
n't want it to go bankrupt
and didn't want to take it over and did
n't go to Paris
to say to the president we have a
one-time chance to take over the thing,
yes where is that and then  we have
no for us it's not and then
I said if he starts it I'll
take care of it we
have it you have to
sign it for two more years until you stay
and that's how it came about it was
n't a budget hotel then it was
really here we  sit in the hotel
so yes they say the most complicated
hotels in resort hotels because that has to
cover the whole range of the hotel industry
and the business does not come by
itself like it is sometimes the case in the city
due to trade fairs and the strong demand
but you have to  make the market
no and provided that it was a good
state and what is that called financing so
you could do it then yes I
paid a market
and took on a lot of debts okay
and then just work off the debts
and okay and then you managed to do it back
then  and then further
and then the Astron
Hotel Group came into being
that was, so to speak, my first chain and
my first brand in that is where I myself
was working as an entrepreneur with a
partner at the time and
we then developed it into 50
hotels 50 pieces, okay, 8,000 rooms in
Germany Austria Switzerland and everything
then anyway hotels on
different city hotels ok
that was another restaurant
hotel ok and then we
did that is what of four stars mostly
area we worked there and
but we all did that no so there was
in
there are countless brands in the four-star area, and um, and
then we thought about going
international, i.e. leaving the
roof region, and then
we actually saw that the market
that we weren’t strong enough, no, the
product wasn’t made strong enough,
but not strong enough  and then
we decided to sell that
you can always be a hotel if you
want to sell there is always someone who
paid around 100 million purchase price was
that always including the
real estate or is it then what that was
ultimately two deals first  was the
operative business that was 130
million at the time with the so with NH
to the Spanish group and then
we had a number of properties that
were initially not sold
and then at some point NH
asked about it,
we can’t we also have the
properties  and then that was
love again, 250 million,
but minus debts, okay,
so of course you financed everything and
then that was
the really big liberation,
then you can
actually come very far entrepreneurially
and then you thought about what
you do it now and you sit down too
quietly I was 50 and then I
thought that might be a bit
early but really you do
n't always try it for a few weeks, so
you had to we had founded Motel One
parallel to Astron 2 years ago
but before that it was all with the other
concept and then we took relatively strong
teams with us, no, and
then there were relatively few hotels
and a strong strong team and then I
thought now I’ll take care
of God that I’ll get better
and then I noticed  that it's
difficult to be as successful
as an entrepreneur then I'd
rather please
okay erm there
is such a short time because of the
80 hotels at that time most are
probably
Germany and then to expand so quickly
I mean we'll talk then
too  It took over
20 years or so or not 15 years to
come up with the first project, so to speak, who financed all this, but
a bank back then banks
financed that, so
similarly, we develop the properties
ourselves and have some in our own
portfolio, but we also have third-party
investors  after the development
or in the development phase,
third
investors take the hotel on board
and we conclude
contracts with them and that depends on which
location you take or on what does it depend on
whether you do it yourself or someone takes it,
no, that's easy,
I say  sometimes
the that's the
most important thing is the location
to secure the good location and the
other is whether I keep it in my possession
or finance it or
give it to a third investor that's the type
of financing and that's often I'll say
one  Opportunity too no so
it is not controlled as it
looks at first glance because often with
good or with the locations there is
simply that the
investors are already ready, they already own the
property no okay they are already waiting for
someone to come now  can start with that
and then you have to say it in
words to get the situation okay and
that's for us to decide
and how we then finance it
almost two pushes is
really the second thing because I
already own a lot of my picture
If you can then own something like that,
it's also valuable, yes, but with
ownership you
always have to make sure that it fits into the
balance sheet ratios. Real estate
is very difficult and of course has
a completely different return on investment
than the operational side of the business and that  in
the mix you always have to make sure that
you have a good mix we
already have a ratio of 30% ownership
70% leased and that is a good
mix with very good returns
telling you what was the success factor
when you started the first business again
this Astron what what
works well and to get to 80 hotel
54 hotels 80 8 rooms but still in
any case the hotel unfortunately also
very much I don't know many
chains um what did you
do right that's how it was back then against
me  tell me a clear strategy in
which cities you want to be and thanks to
Akku I was very well
networked in the market with
real estate developers with makers with
all the players who
are active in this real estate business and of
course that helps enormously and
you can build up speed if
If you do all that, so to speak, I’m going
to Hamburg now and looking for a piece of land,
then you need five times as much time,
no, okay, but then you talk
to Quantum or the big
players and
then it goes much faster, so
we developers from Hamburg, for example,
are okay  at least that was
actually
enough for entrepreneurial life, but then at 50
or shortly before then the Motel One idea
and it was
much better or much more
successful now we know today
how did it go so that's already been
told by others about  At the
beginning it was a bit parallel Exactly at the beginning it ran
parallel, but the idea
behind it was simple, the whole world is moving in
this four-star corn segment,
so all
brands in the world and in the
inexpensive overnight accommodation where actually
the highest demand is
only very few brands
now there are several, but
back then we were almost alone, you can
say, and we thought
the basis was if we did it
well, let me say
this optimized room concept,
if we equip it to a high standard
then it should actually be a huge
success because the  Demand for
cheap accommodation is very high,
but back then there were only etab
and Ibis and then that was it,
no one else was out and about in
this segment
built your room with the tools
uhm a typical hotel if
you know it today i think 16
17 square meters you have everything
planned out in advance so to speak what the
rooms should look like yes
the caretaker probably helped me
that was actually in the Astron  Hotel in
Munich in the exhibition center my large
underground car park and there we have the room, so to speak,
the spatial concept, how small
can you make a room around it and
still feel very comfortable, so that was
the game and then we kept
moving the walls  and light
is always a decisive
factor and also naturally furnished
because the rooms are not furnished, they are
really very small and
then they gain again in the enormous
size that is the economically
decisive factor so efficiency
in the end efficiency is as
few square meters per room as possible  That means that
in order to be able to open a Motel One,
you also have to build a new one by definition, so
you can’t take it over into an existing hotel
and then you have to
make something out of it because we have to tear everything down and
be able to redesign the rooms, yes, that
’s fine, that’s right because
Of course it
wasn't available to buy back
then, of course, in this segment there weren't many other
brands on the way. Now there are
chances of being taken
over
Of the 90 hotels we currently have in
operation, there are only three that have been taken over and
that is Copenhagen Madrid and now in
New York, okay, but you
simply had them, so to speak, they were already
configured so well that you
can describe them like that, somehow it does
n’t quite fit that  comes
that the room concept but overall
it was very well suited because
in addition to the in the rooms are of course
the common areas the public
areas
also decide that they
are also optimized and not the huge
huge um 2000 square meters of
conference rooms and 14 restaurants and
what do I know  have heard in the end
it's the mix for you it's
the location then the room and the
efficiency and then but also although it's
a fairly cheap hotel so
you can currently the the the the
price the mostly applies the fixed price is
80 exactly
and yet when you come in you have
lamps, there are lamps, the
total costs are 100,000 lamps, so there are crass
design objects in your hotel in
Romania
extremely advanced the
basic idea had been
an optimized room concept but
top equipment and that was
actually quite funny at the beginning when we
went to this top designer in Italy
and said yes Motel One we
want it like that no we don’t do it they
couldn't imagine
that their high-end furniture is in a
hotel
and now they're totally happy
and we're in the catalogs and something
I do everything possible because they see
that's great great works no but
the name Motel One has always
protected me  made because I
had to think about my Autobahn when I was at the hotel, which always
sounded very budget-friendly and I
would have thought that it didn't matter and that the
design concept
would have been almost better with a different name, but yes, as the one
from Bavaria, it was deliberately chosen, so
motel is the epitome  for
cheap overnight stays now that was in
i would say in the roof region it's
not very common everyone has
seen a film where it is me but in
itself there were no motels in the
roof region and
we then made it our own
cheap overnight stays
had received the name and wanted
the best and this combination
was always one for me if the
brand name says a lot then
you have already won enormously then
you don't have to explain your marketing expenses you do
n't have to explain what you do no and that
actually worked wonderfully of
course also a bit provocative
ne motel is in the best location in
town you have top facilities and then
everyone wants to see what it
actually is ne
and I mean he
chose turquoise as the color so you are
well that's very
gaudy or it was
deliberately designed to stand out a
color is now something great when a
company identifies itself with a
color or vice versa the company
is identified with the color it's
a great story sleeps  yes
a marketing yes again enormously and to
gain the level of awareness and
then to hold and increase it and there
was turquoise because that is a color that
everyone likes the holiday great
great moods and you just
thought yes exactly so that’s how it came about
Mallorca where I live in a
bay like that and then the water is always Turkish
and that’s okay for us,
so now 90 houses are in operation
I think there are more in it, so to
speak,
how did you get it to grow
otherwise you can read about it there is now
too  A lot of money was also invested
from the cash flow, but
I think the family was the first big investor,
and the family was
already involved with Astron and
when we sold Astron,
we had more or more with the shareholders
less all friends and then
I said to the shareholders
we now have this concept with
Motel One if you want to let me
take half of the money in the company together and everyone
took part and so far the family
has been there for over 30  years
shareholder so you then do the
business with Mr. Hopp the
SAP founder himself not because
this time from the sons but
the father has already done it with us
because Dietmar is
now over 80 and had the
business
of this holding for that  Daniel
another family office very
professional you have to say and very
pleasant but I'll say the pleasant
cooperation that started with Dietmar
and has passed on to Daniel
and it's
a lot of fun yes and then you can get it back at some point in
the morning
exactly in 2007 we
heard that was the last capital
more quickly and I say my relationship
to the company value today was
30 million euros at the time,
everyone would subscribe today
and that was from tomorrow standing
and that made us to my next to the money that
made us  Of course, a certain
professionalism was also brought along, so the
reporting was of course then adapted
to the needs of
Lee in the morning and that was it, let me say the
money was one story, it was
n’t that much and in retrospect
you don’t really call it needed
but  it brought us a lot and
helped us in many things, but that's the
point
and dealing with a bit of real estate and stuff like that
then you know that the money
that was invested there was very, very
little compared to what you  now that
I'm running, I think
in a year I'll have a
turnover of 800 million, then I read
that capital
was built up very efficiently simply because the
cash flow is so good, so the hotels
have always had very quick start-up phases
and  very quickly
generated a good cash flow and that
was always sufficient, so
of course we didn’t make any distributions at all in the first few years, of course, we
invested everything in growth, but the cash flow
was so strong that we managed to take all of the growth,
including real estate development,
out of the  cash flow and
that's actually perpetuum mobile, that
was
great, but the key, if it
can't be the prices because they
're relatively low, then it must
be the omission that
brought you into this situation, so to speak, so
or so that's it  right very clearly that
is of course the
interaction of many factors
first of all this efficiency in the
property itself then to be in the right
locations humor to
achieve occupancy rates to position oneself in terms of price in such a way
that the market really perceives this according to the
concept also prices of overnight stays
and  then on the other hand
organize yourself in such a way that the high
stitches come out that is the
interaction of all these these
factors and if you have a good location
then the occupancy and the price
is fair then the omission is
high on its own so you have to how  you
say no longer make a market but
you can simply connect your system to booking
it will automatically fill up
or how is that so we
prefer to connect to our own network
but of course we also work with
booking no question
I mean
the hotel industry is very busy these days
transparent so the markets are extremely
professional extremely
[music]
transparent when we open konturhaus in Hamburg now
we
we already have a few hotels in Hamburg new
at the Kontorhaus there you can choose
from SDR global in London you can
choose five hotels in the  Environment you know
what occupancy they are doing what
price they are saying and today it is
extremely safe, so to speak, to build a hotel somewhere
simply has all the market cards and then
it is just a matter of
how we want to perform the market
and of course we also have
experience of how  in the hotel one
behaves in comparison to the market what
role does it play because in the end then booking
or or others what how many
percent of the booking come directly
the mark we have about
20%, our
demand comes from booking
yes that is little so we could  we
could live in Germany without booking
and has such a roof region without
booking life booking helps us
enormously if we open a hotel in London now
or open a hotel in New York right now
we are very
happy that this is these these
business opportunities exist where  we then
immediately have an enormous presence and
then there is somehow in the pineapple
next to booking booking is
actually the only one you need so
there used to be in Germany
and Expedia are of course they are
strong in America but in
Germany they have very few
Market shares in Germany is
actually
booking then nothing comes for a long long time
and then and then we beg each other with
booking, so to speak, with our own
platforms we always beg each other with
booking we still have the sense of yes
clearly but of course we
have the key because the last room
is there  it's only through our own
website ah okay that's the trick so
that means at some point you give what you
say now is yes if it
gets really full then you do it all
yourself yes that's so easy it would be
good of course because they they they  Booking
bookings are long, long-
term, so they are well in advance, so they
then book four or five months in advance
and if you only react then
you are actually already full and
then you don’t use it you have to
know your demand times and
the channels early on  close so that it can
only be booked via our own website
we call it channel management and
you always have to be very careful there are
other channels that are relevant
so now booking your own means
what is still exploding
in Germany and your
own where  the visitors come
here, so they are all regular
customers, so to speak, who already know you,
probably what kind of people are they
or how do the people do you did
n't advertise a lot, I have the
feeling it's not like you
see it on TV or that  somehow
now big in marketing no we do
n't actually have the best the the
best marketing is always
the location because it has a good presence
in a city and then
we have very classic tools that we use to
address all companies around the chimney with which cabaret
Make agreements
and then
five years ago, just before Corona,
we actually launched our platform
and we
now have 1.2 million
members and they are frequent travellers,
so they book extremely as a super
database, so of course it
was a short time  during
Corona it stagnated and after Corona it
develops really splendidly
what you and what role does
pricing play so if you have this
fixed price but sometimes at peak times I do
set off and then it goes
higher exactly so
we distinguish a bit from
from the competitors because we
actually love this fixed price model, not
a reliable price, say the 79
€, they have to be bookable 300 days a year
and of course there are events such as the
port birthday in Hamburg, the trade fair and
so in Frankfurt there are events that are long
in advance  where we also
say quite transparently on the Internet there
are those who strike and this
mixture is a
great mixture and very reliable for
the guest today, it just doesn't make it so
if optimization is always held today,
that means that you
look very dynamically in the morning and then you are  the
price suddenly goes up or down by another 10%,
it's often promised
that pricing in general also applies to
aviation or that there's a lot of
margin to be had and you
said that, but I'm saying goodbye to that,
I don't actually have anything to do with it  to
do exactly so we really have it's
also a very complex model and
of course the guest finds it difficult
to see why you called this morning I
called it cost 79 in the
afternoon hour later it
cost 109 so it's not for a guest
not transparent and not, uh,
visible and
we wanted to build up a brand, a
reliable brand and that was
extremely well done with this fixed price with the
but on the noses
that you do without, I mean I ca
n’t always do something about management
hears that there are somehow huge
optimization possibilities and that
only goes down and there
are such extreme examples in
London then suddenly
the room at the competitor costs 19 pounds on Sunday evening
oh really and during the week it
costs 189 from ne okay do that  So
it's going down too,
so it's not just so
blissful bringing it up, it's
also going down and the fatal thing
about these systems is
that they are algorithms and they are
fed by all the hotels that supply the data
and it can also happen that
they pull each other down,
so you say they should actually
look at the competitor, who
now has more and then we take more,
ne so that's actually that helps
management and of course that's considered a long time in
advance  and then there's
past data, I know all
sorts of things,
but it's also going down and then
you always have to be really careful that
the whole industry doesn't
pull down and we always
stayed out of it
and said our hotel cost
59 or 49 euros at the time  even and the
guest can rely on it and then
we found that there are many who
no longer look at it but the
knowledge Motel One had reliable
prices and don't look at all this
game like where can I
stay overnight even cheaper so but in the end
probably  a disruptive
decision i always look
for the reasons why it
worked in such conversations i already
understand this fox edition this
efficiency in the rooms but in the end
also a summer
contra pricing decision because you
always think you have to approach it this way or
analytically and  then you say
no, I'm pulling myself out of there and that
actually brought about success, so with
responsibility,
now I still have to prove
whether, for example, New York is such an
extreme market that we're in now, where it's
extremely geidet and then
we still have to  So we still have to
prove that this is also possible. Now
you had this growth in Germany for a few years
and then Corona came with the obvious
problem
that he was afraid of losing the company,
then short-time work such
opportunities
came through relatively cheaply  is ne so yes no no
no so Corona was of course a
huge shock ne because that is yes you are
suddenly only a passenger in your
own company and somehow he
said you can no
longer take the guest but only the one who
is traveling on business and
can prove with confirmation from
his company or what do I know
you can take it that's actually
a disaster no and that with them
had to be digested first no and
but the human being
is well constructed he can
always always react to situations
and we then did that relatively
quickly, we were able to
adapt to it and then
developed strategies on how we could get through it, if
possible not dismissing any employees
and and and and and
we got through really well,
you have to say, I don't want to say that
we didn't lose any scratches  If I were to
count the profits we would have made in
this phase, we probably
lost half a billion here, wow, but
we ended
up starting at zero with
subsidies and short-time work, of course, colder and
it was always possible to end up at plus minus 0,
yes, but that's pointless
Of course it's pointless to think about it,
it's just like that, where that
says I mean say we
last announced that, I think
in the last closed financial year,
sales were then 620 million and you
then manage to achieve a 20% increase on that,
about no, well
He's already doing over 100 million results
and that
obviously motivated you or even before that to
say we're going even further, we're
really going a bit to New
York, so why do you do what's really
after New York,
yes, the idea is of course  to
build up a global company and we have
structured our development strategy in stages where we said that the
first stage is Germany, of course, our
home market where we are very well connected
where we are able
to grow relatively quickly and then
expanded to the roof region of
Austria and Switzerland  the second
stage was certain metropolises in
Europe, such as Paris, Madrid, Barcelona,
London, that was the second stage,
we've already done everything,
but
I'll say the stages are never
finished, they build
on each other, so
of course we'll continue  in Germany we
continue to develop in London,
Paris and also in European
capitals and the third stage is
then the USA
and then there will certainly be another fat
Asia and the goal is already a
global company with global brands,
so that means a role model is a
bit like that  Hilton or or Marriott
or whatever it is, we
showed that it works,
no, there was a Hilton and I was
inspired a bit and there is
a saying I think you particularly
like, so when Hilden was
asked what  the success of
his company or of a
hotel in general then he gave me the
lagellack so we don't need to talk about anything
else if that's true then
you've actually
achieved 90% of the success and
I've always taken that to heart
really
we have a one
a location network that really
has an exceptional quality of locations
and we also work with booking
with our own ratings and
we have an average location rating of
our houses of 9.2, i.e. 9.2 out of 10
and I didn't know which other
hotel chain in the world did that  has which
hotel chains do you think are
still inspiring besides Hilton which
do a good job which ones are you
looking at so there are a lot of listed hotels are there any that appeal to you
yes of course we like to look at
the luxury sector because we do too  Let me say that
in terms of equipment and
service, we want to
embody these values, the luxury hotels, we also want to achieve
and achieve that, so we
don't benchmark ourselves with the
budget hotel around the corner,
we benchmark ourselves in terms
of friendliness  Cleanliness,
the things that you can influence so well,
then we always benchmark ourselves with
the best hotel
Hotels like Bayerischer Hof so icons
yes its four seasons so real
customers where you can orientate yourself quite well
but who would have in the world is
always a Hilton I have they are according to
market caps I think over 50
will be exactly so
still the  best-known brand and and
also sometimes with the most sales
or at least the most successful do
exactly okay because they also have a lot of
houses worldwide that's exactly what
we bought and then merged
with the Starwood and have really
great ones but I mean if you put it that way
listen then it is now at least clear
married is still a long way 50
billion marks but if you
look at it
if you
would make 200 million in earnings next year and the
malte pill is always around 20
times the result, you can say that  yes, so
between 10 and 15 okay the
properties must have been considered separately 20
or 25 okay okay but then still would have been
on the stock exchange and then compare a little bit
then at 200 million
you come to a market cap of 3 billion
what the company is then worth and that  is
then of course still a fraction of
married but it is somehow
no longer quite inconceivable that you
can get there very small players
we no longer know what the value
of the company is but we hope we
assume that we are
heading towards 300 million  are
and then talk about about 4 billion
companies
yes,
why have other German
hotel chains never succeeded so we
always talk
about married and Hilton with hotel chains and everything
international for Germans do you miss
your why that is so
interesting I have
often  thought about it because we had,
for example, Steigenberger
Steigenberger because he was a great pioneer
and then also
built up an awful lot, so admirable and very
early on had an academy and all sorts of things,
but it always had successors that are
n’t good, so we
’re not developing well, let’s put it this way
so and then there was a lot of
change of ownership and it was
never good for the company it
would have been a company that
was on the market very early on and that actually would
have had the chance
to play in this game of the big players internationally, I would say, but that
's somehow  you didn't succeed in the
end Management that was an absolutely
pure management question if you
also have a few
beliefs that you can read that
are also quite different from other
places or, for example, a whole
star concept of how many stars a
hotel has so believe  you do
n't at all, you look more
down-to-earth for the evaluation of
Pokémon on the net that that's actually
what's decisive for you,
so of course it also has something to do with us
with the beginning
and when we
became a mother and was the first
hotel brand  that
had already happened a lot on the Internet and focused very much on
the Internet
and then it was already obvious that
it was no longer constant but
really about reviews and
at the time nobody really
noticed that the feedback from the guests
then  no longer in
long letters or anything else
that comes immediately the next day or
on the same day it is actually
on the internet and the hotels did
n't publish it on their websites for a long time
and we then said very quickly
that it was up to us
always annoyed by this
classification
by stars and the condition of the houses
never played a role, so
you had read five stars
and then you came and there were
queried booths, so to speak, but the
stars were partly correct, whether there
was a pool or not  not but if there was
a star or or was [ __ ]
but it was still there and then that is
rated exactly and that is
now much more transparent with the
ratings and you can now
look at the details which is
good  what is not so what form is
important for it so our own
because we have the largest base
we have about 450,000 ratings
our
hotels are based on so that’s a
market I’d say a value that you don’t get
in any market research
but what does that mean on your
websites people who then say to you
themselves every guest who stays with us
usually we have the
e-mail address of the guest
then gets the evaluation e-mail from us okay and but
that's just  you're
interested in that on our
website okay okay okay all right, including
the bad ones and then it's absolutely
forbidden to follow up on them or
anything else
they stay as they are and then
there's a rating on booking
and then there's a rating on Google where are
you looking  still there and actually
only booking because we have
structured the question sheets in a similar way to
booking so that we can also compare them
and Google is not important so Google
yes, take a look at them so if we
have such a company it
is called Traction  it
summarizes all the ratings and
Google is there too okay okay but in the end
they are not as comparable as
booking is now because we have
structured it in the same way that there are the same
criteria that can be evaluated
and are there any things
that you explosively  changed because it was in
the rating so the whole
lot yes really the product
development of Motel One really
forgot with the feedback
today a lot a lot vegan things organic at
some point we completely
switched over afterwards that was actually such a
feedback that always
There were more guests, no, and then initially there were
no safes in the rooms,
so we retrofitted them ourselves, so
many little things, I don’t have them
all ready now, but so many
little things in product
development, breakfast wasn’t a
little thing, but that
probably helps  already a small thing
and he has done it so much further
developed
many things even more differently
in the sense that you
said right from the start with the point development
okay we don't need a few things
no telephone in the room
bathroom doesn't have to be particularly big
it's all whether then your
gut feeling even at the beginning you
say do without a few things but
I think the television is important because
it's also important at the beginning there's always a
television in it and so how was
that ne so make a phone at the beginning
even a little revolution even so
we weren't making a phone very early
today it's no longer an issue at all
and in the first reviews it
was always he no phone and
security and what do I know but since
today really everyone has a cell phone and of
course we always check that one
Cell phone reception there is
not an issue at all, but do you have other things,
but particularly disruptive or
unusual? We
noticed an
extreme example
of what we don't have yet, so paying
was also a small revolution that
always annoyed me in the morning when I was in the
hotel  and I
had to stand in line to tear it off because I do
n't have time, we're the
dates of the planes or whatever,
and then we said we'll
pay at check-in and the guest can
then throw in his card and leave
if he wants to  isn't that was a a
a little revolution back then
was of course
connected with the fact that we didn't
keep a mini
because if you had some excuse and the
guest couldn't bill the room
but yeah it's all clear that's the
consequence of it ne and that has  then of
course always
filled with discussions but ultimately
the guest has the positive that he
can simply go in the morning where he
has the stress
that all broken up
which expansion because is not an issue
which which which expansion which
European hiking the most difficult
was all that in Europe  relatively similar
so now you have London Passion from
Paris was everything similar from the or
was things surprised so
we always find that when
you go to a new country it's always
a little adventure no so for the
whole organization if you  in the country
then it's a new hotel
Dennis also does like putting a plug in
the socket no and
insofar as I
talk to my employees then they
could be the man every country that
causes stress but of course I'll say it
Eastern Europe Poland Warsaw
Prague they are still very
complex why is it I'll
say the tax
requirements
it's really complex well I know I
'm not really into the details
but I ask my financiers
then they
say God's hotel market in the world  so
if you are new york then you can do
everything ne and the colleagues from
marriott and they welcomed us for help
and have fun in new york
but how does it look at the moment so
yes we are very happy it has
developed really well  because the
hotel is staffed differently in that respect exactly
not one we've always toyed with the
idea of ​​conveying a second brand
and then the USA was the
right trigger for it and then it's
really, really I'd say from marketing
a great story you develop
a brand  in New York and goes back with it
but where is the house in New York that
right on 9.11
great location so you look right down so
exactly and but only there are indicators that it
works or that doesn't
work already so it was a we are like that
we  we remodeled we
took over that remodeled during the pandemic
it was another
branded hotel it was in Gotha
and we then remodeled it while it was in operation,
which
is always a bit of a problem and then
also
brought us negative reviews, which
are now slowly changing through the  Repeating amounts
[music]
and
I'd say it was
a bit of a difficult time between October and March
and now we're on
the way to 80% capacity utilization,
so we're assuming that we'll
perform the market sometime, but you have to  it
's just a bit longer that the brand is better known
right at the end there's a bit more detail
about the brand and of course also about the
environment it's such a
business location and you just have to make
agreements with your body now and introduce yourself
people here
get
what it costs to make such a new hotel back
then, especially New York, but
if you take the new one in Hamburg, let's take it
as an individual project, then it
depends on the property and then what
do you have other costs then things
on  you can say something in
Hamburg, uh, a hotel like that costs
€200,000 per room staying in a hotel is
okay and then you have
rooms
400 400 what is a really
big investment
but that means that you can still do it
now  also in how many
hotels do you have right now in the construction area,
we have 90 open now and have a
pipeline of 116, so there are 26 houses,
but you are a big customer at Deutsche Bank or
at banks around the world,
so if you can open it all,
yes  didn't finance everything,
but then had to do everything with
borrowed capital and that means
your day-to-day work, but banks, uh,
say 26 houses in parallel, have just heard the construction with
the costs again,
that's a volume that you're
putting off,
we have a very good one  Balance sheets Very
strong balance sheet Good balance sheet ratios and
are very welcome at banks
Bricks
don’t really make the
interest rates because they’re extremely low, but you have to
say that’s good for you and of course
good for us, but
I’d say from a historical
perspective there are now four  Percent
interest not not much
it's just in consideration I'll say
two years ago it was just 0.5
or 0.75 something that's extremely much but that
tolerates that the
hotel business is very good so we're
not that close together
set up by the measurements that this
would now be a big factor for us our times
um
other economic development also
inflation
you notice that simply because there
are fewer tourists or is that somehow
so inflation is a
big issue for everyone, of course, and and then
of course we don’t have to  always
look at our own costs, so that we can
always balance that with the price,
no, and we
actually manage that quite well, that we
have the brand has the
price power to also
absorb inflation, but nevertheless the demand does
not sing because of conventional
Yes, we always find that phases like this
are not bad for us
because when companies start to
save money, we find that
many people come to us and
don't see it as a punishment because we
have a great product and a travel
manager can do it  Of course,
savings can be made very quickly if he now from
I would say from a hotel that costs 200 euros
to one that costs 79 euros, no, if
your biggest competitions are, so to speak,
the biggest competitors that
have developed in this way in the last few years,
so the big competitor was always
Ibis  been and but
now again divided into three different brands
and there was now
the Ibis
roof magically or something like that or the highest
higher brand was also in the center
more in the center
that was always the
classic competitor but
you could always  pretty good so it was
i talked to the farmers
too we didn't notice
when ibis opened up next to us and
they noticed me when a mother
wanted to get up because
the markets have been extreme even in the last ten
years  you have to say it has grown
and so there was
always a need for new hotels, so
a dear one belonging to Aquana
would say yes, they have
over 1000 hotels in Europe and
that means they are of course on
every corner  about the
baker and are also an inexpensive
an inexpensive segments on the way
extremely extremely discussed let me
say the classic Airbnb
only now
family father with his two children
rents one in Amsterdam for a week that wasn’t necessarily our
customer because he has to be with us
also rent two rooms and erm otherwise
the room is a bit
so we never noticed it
but it was always discussed extremely
and of course it was also
compensated by the extremely
increasing number of transfers in the
markets so happy in my opinion at some
point  published that they
do over a million overnight stays in Berlin no
and everyone was
amazed where it suddenly now
from the market didn’t notice it no
and then they actually expected the market
because the market didn’t have
Airbnb further but the market as
a whole  extremely because you
could fly so cheaply that was of course
for the city tourism the
cheap flights in an extreme motor ne
so completely different factors the
overnight market has grown so much the last 10 years
is simply good economy
namely cheap flights yes good and
I  I'll say the increasing
shopping worldwide, so
Germany always says that incomes
are not increasing when I
look around in this world where we are
moving in Hamburg or Munich that
's yes, but you notice that the
extreme standard of living
is actually there too  Of course there is also a
huge difference, one has to
say, but from a
global perspective,
incomes have risen. China has
developed an extreme middle class and
global travel has been extreme in recent years.
Which foreign
nationality do you have, but we know
you too  Guest so where do
most of them come from when I’m German yes we
are actually in
the statistics like the individual cities are
also so but the hotel industry
has almost 50% overnight stays abroad
in Germany
and of course these are primarily the neighboring countries
English French
Spanish and of course also USA and in
the last few years China had
become very much a part of it
the Russian market was always a
bit
strange so because you
were only high end we
don't feel that at all so Airbnb again I
had the Erwin a few weeks ago  B
founder was a guest in the podcast and he
described it to me as if he
really would also go on a day
overnight business trip,
as if that were their path too,
but also surprised because you
always have the picture in mind, then
people drive  for a week and would
really have to visit and where and
instead but that seems
to be the case too but you still don't notice it
well I always assume a bit
whether I like it
now when I'm staying
somewhere  and then somewhere in the
stranger's apartment
until I've found everything it's
the night that's actually over
and the price differences are here to the
hotel they're not there have you
ever owned any shares
they just don't
find good communication because they  with
so towards the guests yes but
towards them
they really don't do that well because
they are really hated in every
city and everyone to
stop these illegal rentals
can meanwhile because that
was all Barcelona Amsterdam everybody
complains extremely about Airbnb and  that's what
he does RB does a lot of things great but
that doesn't do Airbnb well and still
I find the brand management as such
that they try to if there
is a crisis at some point then
they charge or then you write
you pay your hosts for the
overnight stay yourself if he  then because somehow
refugees are supposed to be taken in or
people who are suffering in some way because
they are already committed they
are very strong such a brand that
tries to be a bit as modern as
Spotify in Netflix airbn as such a
modern beloved brand  what
you also wish for for mother
when as Markus you are also
a little bit in this world of Spotify
Netflix brands
so I was always very proud of it and
uh and I think it is part of the
concept for success that we are very
are broadly based and don't
focus on a single target group and that's
why it wasn't like that for us,
I'll say we didn't
happen in such a way that we are at home in this world,
but
with which we are often asked what happens to their
guests  not be because it
is so broad and so broad and
that worked extremely well and that
's also the nice thing if you really
narrow your position, the more
difficult it becomes and then
you are more vulnerable regardless of
what you decided  to say some time ago
I'm going out of operations
and do are supervisory board members why
actually my do you notice that
how far I've found my way
not at all so that at all yes
well that's just the question at the beginning
I mean I'm in a
69  I want to be 70 next year and
I did that for an extremely long time
and I
have a very strong management team, so
if Daniel
[music]
intro history, well, your son
have known each other orally
for many years and he has now
succeeded, so to speak, as CEO  so
greetings Daniela are you listening to the
exam you have the best
so anyway that had prescribed to me
legendary story um well anyway
but it's still unusual
a lot of entrepreneurs but
we really like to kiss and we
've been he was in his mid 80's is
still somehow relatively tight  on it or
the group or out mine are
all very close so
you want to consciously step back or have you
officially initiated it now yes
no I initiated it quite consciously
Corona came so I
actually wanted it a little earlier
then  Corona got in the way and
then I did
n't want to live through the biggest crisis of this
company, so to speak, then I had to
make the change and when it
was clear what's happening with Corona now,
we
actually initiated it in the last Corona,
right?
consciously
because I am of the opinion that the
management must be rejuvenated, so
I can of course always
try to stay on the ball, but that
also requires an enormous amount of
effort and at some point you are
no longer willing
to spend all that effort, i.e. energy
my sign of the time to stay and there
was always Dietmar Hopp for me as a
big example, who then said
that he had a one who, at 59,
he resigned from SAP as a member of the Management Board, there
was still a certain amount of
time in the office, there it was  then also,
in contrast to his friend, you have
Plattner, who is still on what he is today, he
flourished the others and he
always said he is in an
industry either you are fully involved
and try to recognize all developments there
in time or  but you
go out and
our industry is not so extreme now
that the development then takes place in such an extreme way
that always announces itself a
bit longer but nevertheless there is
always a lot happening where you
always have to be vigilant and I
believe
that the young management can
do much better
unusual freedom know your son
who does quite well but still does the
question asks you with all
entrepreneurs, so to speak, who
have built something comparable, the probability, from a
purely statistical point of view, that
the successor, so to speak, or the the the the son
or the  daughter
has exactly the same talent as the father
in that case is super
improbable, so that's
not the case in football either, so that he'll never be
one of Messi again, then he's not
in the first team in Barcelona and
now you're already, so to speak  in the
absolute top league of German
entrepreneurs,
why do you think we can
see it working like that or just
feel like it or something like that well I have well
daniel is great together with
Stefan Lenze and I've been together with both of them for
13 years now
worked
with Stefan Lenzer for eight years
so I know both of them very well
where their strengths are and she recognizes
them extremely well and what you said
is the biggest mistake you
could make that you think other people
do it the same way  You
simply do it differently and
probably even better, so and I am
firmly convinced, for example, that
Daniel has different talents than I
have, then
he is very operationally strong, he can extremely
win people over
and motivate them to follow a path
and
I have it  also somewhere but
then he is, for example, much stronger he does not make the
knowledge maybe so child is
always observed with joy and
and at some point accepts that he
is completely different from me but still
a very clever head and
has actually moved in this time
and has  then fully trusted him
to do it, but the company
is of course so big now and
so 3,000 people
3,000 people internationally that
I found this constellation to be very good
and the Supervisory Board also
supported it and he  has been
doing it for two or three years now
and is doing it really well what are
the biggest risks
what are the biggest giant
companies I know what that is right now
you definitely have to stay on the ball
so that you are not so left behind or that you
are surprised where  you see so
up-to-date the dangers the houses are
slowly getting on in years I mean the
first houses now even then a
few years old it's so you can tell
okay ten years ago it was chic and it
was cool is now it's not
maybe anymore  or will others come what
is the biggest concern, for example,
such trends no, well, it's this one,
I mean we were one of the first
lifestyle brands ever and
now we're coming into this
lifestyle segment a lot and you have to
see where  really goes there
on the way and of course it's
incredibly exciting what's happening there
and and exciting brands are coming there and you
have to be careful that you don't let me say you
stop at design concepts
like they were 15 years ago  no, for
example, at the beginning they said you said
this this the color turquoise that is
still our
color but we use it
much more discreetly today than we did 15 years ago and and
certain service tools and and and and
the bars will always be  better and
the loungeons and then ruftops
we do today and so these are things where you
just have to develop and you
just have to say that then you have to
look around a lot what's happening
in general it's great that my feeling
if you've missed a trend or
you notice something is going against us here,
then it's just incredibly difficult
to take countermeasures because everything is also very
long-term, so the contracts until
Nutella is built, then it's
finished and then you can't
change it again immediately, um, it's a very
long-term business, right?  but then
you can go back to the to the to the
warehouse to the Konrad Hilden
should if that's right, the adaptation
of concepts is always possible no
of course our industry is
a bit more sluggish than the digital world where
everything is much faster but we
also have to  For example,
renovation rhythms are between 7
and 10 years and then you can see
something like that ahead of time
and you mentioned
that the hotels are
getting older and
we actually have that from the beginning
but because I’ve experienced that
with other brands  Tip Brands then
lost their image at some point because the
houses simply went bad
and we built up a renovation rhythm right from the start
that we do
n't build up any traffic jams at all, but
really always
successively the houses like a
machine, so to speak, now it's this house's
turn after the  Let's take a
close look at the calendar and rethink the
concept how can you make it
fresher, younger
and more contemporary, also
incorporate other elements and you also
say quite openly that
one day IPO will also be a
topic that people say okay that  has the
size is now open it
has reached investors get out in the morning
so that's something that
could happen absolutely
I mean companies of this
size just have to be open
to thinking for the capital market whether it
's an IPO or we have
uh Stanley he  it's already the second
round
it's already been recapitalized in
this form
we have financial investors on board who
always want to get out at a certain rhythm
25% no 25 yes so there would be
a chance for you too tell me the
assets would be liquid yes
you have any ideas  something to do with it so there
is an option for you to say
I want another 10%.  we're talking
about 100 million that would be for
sale
you should never say never because
things are of course constantly changing I mean
it's always like that
as long as we have this growth I see that
in our financial investors also
in the main family as long as we do
can represent this growth and like
it so developed and the
marshes are so great it is
incredibly difficult to find alternative investments
insofar as
there is no compulsion to do that at all
but I never rule anything out
but you also have we are now
right now in a hotel privately heard
by three pieces here in Chiemgau
in Bavaria
you do that on the side, so to speak, so you
told the hotel from the beginning
the first thing that ever
ended up with you in the end is a hobby like that
on the side
no that’s
how  I said I've now got on my bike, I
'm no longer operationally active
and there
are often successful entrepreneurs
who then invest in completely different industries
and
then he was making a lot of mistakes, I
just don't understand anything about the industry
and
I just do it the other way around and
invest  so to speak privately in the
hotel industry because I think
I understand something about it and it is natural that
was also a very
pleasant constellation or or
a great nice coincidence that these
two hotels here in Chiemgau and
then Kitzbühel the Kitzhof that
the Spaniards wanted at the time  don't buy
them but we don't want the two hotels in the
mountains, so
they stayed with me, so always with
you, I thought
in the company,
so to speak, and then at some point we
said we wanted to have a clinic
company and then we'll have
it  bought out
together you do that's already
our
involvement with a woman is always
a bit maybe even
neglected is very relevant because I think she
's also done a bit of the design over the years
for Motel One and now here  this has
also become a hotel designer, so to speak, exactly so
she has a very
significant something he has yes she does yes
dermio has been at the moment
still because we are looking for a successor for
her and she had many so the
design mask determines yes the
body color  actually comes from her
and the consequence really
now, for example, to only take top brands
and no fakes so a Jakobs
and students are really
hotel ministers are you actually
crazy why that wasn’t neighbors
to the children or something like that but that was from
the beginning
I’ll say  her
requirement that is actually me sticking
with these but man we also want to
be a top model and we do
n't want to become a fake
crass madness story so
you could probably
have imagined that it's so unbelievably
exposing it's not in the end I
mean if we now  there are still a few things
that you've been planning to do one
day you've already said it's
also conceivable then it just kept
getting clear so
the world is big so there is one and that's what
the big big brands are proving
that it's possible  No, that
you can position yourself globally
and
since we have proven in every new market that we have
entered
that the concept
works in this market, there is
actually nothing to be said against it since
it is to be rolled out further globally. I am
currently looking for risks and
where it is  the snag now strikes me
could be an issue, namely you
need a lot of workers, and every
hotel
is on the road, so to speak, is there when
the market is a bit of a
job where a
lot of people have been looking for work
now to a  where now there is
a shortage of work, so to speak, people are already being found
at various levels.
Service is what you see as the top
risk for you, to be
honest, no,
of course there are always
situations where it is much tighter,
but that has a lot to do with the
companies  even ne so especially
in our industry
low salaries bad
working hours let me
say a bad tone
and
what what I what what all
has led to the industry getting
a bad bad image as an
employer and we actually
tried to do that from the start
we have invested a lot
in this employer brand
were in the hotel and have a very good
image as an employer we have always
paid a little better than others have
done incentive systems that were based on the
ratings we
want to build a university together
with the eu  bh in Bad Honnef and then
dual studies started very early and
the academy where the mother wants
employees
I would say now worldwide then
come to the company and then
get the spirit and and and there is also an
enormous appreciation for the employees,
which is not common in our industry
is no longer there are then you
get them then yes but we
have seen that now
in the pandemic so we
tried to keep our employees
of course there was a flight station that we did
n’t move during the pandemic and
went away  business
started immediately after the pandemic and we were much
too close to the employees but it did
n't take half a year so far we
had the status we
actually need and
[music]
I didn't see that our
hr division
I'll say it man  that that doesn't
work and
this this this image that has
built up for us helped us enormously,
so
keep thinking about it in the future,
even if the employees will be
before you many are missing them
somewhere else because you're simply its strong
you can do it that way and many also for
do the training and and and and
actually I have to do the the entire
industry
and if we don't go along with it later
and he has the problem
of course you have to be careful now that
in this digital world there aren't
two class societies,
so the straight people discuss the employees
about four days a week
Mondays are not there
to Spain and what do I know no that
's all great and we
try to
make it possible somehow only 95% of
our team are in the hotels that
means we have to be shy about it
they five days a week and and and
so then you have to be careful that there is
no
two-class society no and
then no one goes into the service
and I now believe, for example,
that
will help there, so
I'm really convinced that that because it will then  I'll say
that the highly qualified
jobs are replaced, they
have the stress with you, goodbye, people
don't have that, that means that only
people from the office
have to give up completely because they will then be
replaced by
the no but most in most yes
so me  At least try
to be there for the opening and
then also stay overnight, but I did
n’t succeed in all of them. What is it
again now that you do so much
hotel business and have also looked at it yourself so much
what is yours or
these are your two  two three
favorite hotels in the world oh that
's always his because we always
discuss it in the management and the
supervisory board and we always have the
latest that everyone thinks
is great it's just now Innsbruck has just
opened
that's of course a
great hotel  Innsbruck
that's the best you say right
now, yes, you feel it now because
we were just working on it ruftop and then
the Nordkette your Innsbruck that's
fine and apart from mother when is there
then if he
lets himself be inspired, so to speak, where are you going that
you  since your in the world where you said
yes well I like it is so
traditional hotels I actually
quite like so in Paris the
the houses
luxury houses that is of course
quite nice so no resorts
anywhere in the Seychelles or
Thailand of course of course  you've
looked at everything so it
's professional you have to
but the Paris is it the best
hotel in town yes I think so yes I
should have my podcast was with Mr.
Harris from the landserhof I
asked the question yes exactly  and he
said to me uhm Dubai is totally
impressive because the service level is
so high and Dubai what he from the
hotels is yes Christian is always
faster than me he is
always has seen everything that will be
discussed
ok ok thank you very much  Awesome conversation
yes good luck I'm curious how
natural I am promise how it
goes on
yes almost all performance yes thank you very much I
'm sure Daniel it will be on
other heights for everything clear
ciao ciao